so
what's up everyone it's me tomorrow
hussein managing editor of gamespot.com
and it is a momentous day on the
internet and in the world of video games
it is overwatch to bait a day baby
that means
we will
fingers crossed
be able to jump into some overwatch 2
which is going to be fun
but there's a decent chance that we will
instead spend a lot of time waiting
to get into overwatch 2.
i am of course
committed to at least an hour and a half
of this and i've managed to drag in a
couple of friends with me
who have we got
we've got jordan remay
oh man i was muted heyo what's
up and we've got the one and only ben
janka
hello there happy to be here still
downloading but you know what
yeah jordan what what state is your game
at currently
mine is at the state that it boots up
the game it's like all right we're ready
to go and i'm like cool and i try to
jump in and then it just crashes and
it's like nah
you hate to see it you hate to see it
well i'm happy i'm excited to reveal
that i have the game up
so while you guys are figuring that
stuff out
yeah while you guys are figuring that
out i'm gonna try and jump into some
unranked gameplay
i'm gonna do a quick play
uh
actually i'll go all just so we give
myself a better chance
um meanwhile folks in the chat just let
me know if everything is working okay
can you hear me okay can you see
everything okay
um and we'll go from
there um i have a mechanical keyboard so
you you folks are going to hear some
clickety clacking that's all i'm saying
there's going to be some buttons being
pressed let me tell you
i'm going to try and move my keyboard
away from the mic but
we'll see how it goes seeing the
gameplay you're gonna be hearing the
gameplay you're gonna hear me heavy
breathing into the microphone and we are
starting with of course
gibraltar
um
oh
someone's already picked mercy
who do i play
i'll play i'll play moira
let's do moira let's see moira seems to
be largely unchanged
i mean i think
healers now i believe have passive heal
i need to take this down first
oh no up a bit
um i think healers have so i played a
bit of this in um
in like the early alpha stuff that they
gave us access to
so i um
have some experience with it and you can
see some of the really cool ui stuff
that's happened like the ui looks very
similar there's a lot this is gonna
important to mention of course this is a
beta and obviously it's gonna look very
very familiar to you in a lot of ways
but there are some small little changes
that i do like for example when you're
getting killed by a mercy it pops up
above your player icon or your player
profile which looks really nice
um
there's a lot of like communication
stuff that they've improved
which i'm into
um i was playing in the alpha
and let me tell you the alpha was a
was an interesting experience for us
because we were in there with overwatch
league players
um there's so john the new ability new
character um we were in there with
overwatch league players who were
absolutely cleaning our clock constantly
um this is bad
oh geez louise um
so uh this is gonna be the first time
i'm playing with people who aren't
overwatch league players and i'm also a
bit rusty
um
doomfist now a tank
oh
there's a here's a look at the new um
scoreboard it's i like it more info more
clean this scoreboard feels like it's
designed specifically for um
overwatch league like the the stats on
display are like
just uh telling you a lot of information
compared to previous the previous
iteration
uh
let's see if i can
i got her i got one
so there's gonna be a lot there's a lot
of people in chat saying looks the same
took three years for a new update um it
does look the same it does look very i
mean like it looks better it looks
cleaner it looks um
a little more sharper
but yeah it is
it's important to remember the bulk of
what they took time to make isn't in
this since they uh decoupled
where are you going
oh my god need healing and then ran away
um they decoupled single player and
multiplayer
um and a significant portion of the
development effort was in single player
um the multiplayer was in a much better
spot
than um
was in a good spot decent spot um
by the time they announced overwatch 2
and started working on it well before
that i imagine
so i'm not surprised that there's not a
lot of difference with what's going on
here
um
and they're they're operating on oh good
lord
they're operating on a if it ain't broke
don't uh fix it
approach
for the multiplayer which depending on
your perspective maybe it is broke
um some people would argue it is
get out of here um
but yeah uh see that i just stopped to
chase down that doomfist
it's been a menace to me
uh yeah so a lot of the
the bulk of the stuff that is gonna be
different is gonna be in that single
player but it's been decoupled and
they're releasing the multiplayer first
to get it out sooner no doubt obviously
to get the overwatch league folks like
in a better position so they can
play
and compete
i got a smart smart call to me yeah
who needs a healing you need a healing
god let me enter the game why
welcome to beta day baby
jordan your overwatch 2 beta experience
is going to be you sitting on a title
screen
um
ben i don't know if you're monitoring
chat but let me know if there's any
questions in there and i'll do my best
to
pat my head and rub my stomach as it
were like
the people questioning why they've
changed to five players some people
saying it looks so similar
it does look kind of similar of course i
already covered that um
in terms of changing it to five players
i think it's a really interesting move
it feels
it feels like a quicker game now and it
there's far less stalemates i can like i
feel comfortable in saying like shield
watch is over
for now
um like you're not gonna be like pelting
shields constantly um
i i find like stuff like this is
happening way more like you get
fights are resolving quicker
um
oh
fights are resolving quicker
and um
there's less like stalemates like i
mentioned and the 5v5 is what enables
that
um
yeah i haven't played it myself but i
think 5-5 is a good shoe yeah the tricky
thing is
it's a good mechanical and gameplay
design decision
it's a bad social and real life playing
together decision because i don't know
about like my my group of friends that
plays overwatch is six people and it has
been that way i know now what happens
like one of us
try and stay on that
one of us is gonna have to like sit out
constantly which is not great
um
yeah
yeah the lighting is better it looks a
little sharper and cleaner
so there definitely have been some
changes made to the style of it
obs winston
um
got a very important question uh asking
how do you make your beard look so great
uh be have a pakistani jeans have a
south asian jeans here's the thing right
everyone's like oh your bed looks great
and that is the fundamental reason is
because i'm hairy okay the downside of
that is i'm hairy everywhere okay the
rest of that is not a good equation
we got our people like i think i can't
remember who said this but
the powers that be made us hairy and
then put us real close to the sun which
is
a cruel cruel thing to do
um
but
other than having good jeans
you can like use beard oil
drink loads of water uh
come here
drinking drinking good amounts of water
is always just a good life yeah it's
just just you know
got to work on it that was great
let's see what else we got people
talking about here
it does feel good to be back in
overwatch honestly
yeah it's been a while for me too
i've i've got like
probably
thousands of hours in this game at this
point
oh god
how is she deflecting
that it's a beam how well is she
deflecting
[Music]
i'm upset by this
it should just go through the beam
oh this is bad i just need to take out
that mercy all i need to do is take out
that messy let me have that mercy god
dang it
have they got rid of the have they got
rid of the booties
i'm not sure what booties you you are
talking about but
i don't think they've removed booties
entirely
that would be very very unfortunate for
everyone in overwatch that needs to take
a
dump that would be uh i think
i net positive booties in this yeah even
in the speeder that's a bug you need to
fix that someone says in the chat i
believe
as you can see this is not going well
for us
but you know what i'm i'm not surprised
at all
our team has not been coordinating
i should switch off but
i mean
i'm playing dude feels good i'm playing
a healer
do it feels right
maybe i can be a bit annoying
get some aoe heals push people off nope
i cannot be annoying
uh
defeat is how we began
magnificent well done
i'm gonna put in the chat
this
this is my first time playing overwatch
how do i upgrade my character
what a neat game
where's that new original
will the better be available on consoles
uh yes
eventually not currently though i
believe that's what they said
i'm gonna pick my girl
zarya
are you getting to the beta you just
sign up
you have to sign up a couple weeks ago
you have to
at midnight go to a mirror turn the
lights off light two candles and say
overwatch beta 32 times into the mirror
and then jeff goodman appears
and hands you a piece of paper with a
key on it
that's how it works
oh look at this dog
all right is this a new map queen street
it is
all i have now is a black screen and
overwatch 2 isn't even allowing me to
open up my task manager to force it to
close you've been taking my computer
it's taken over my life it just
your computer is now overwatch too
congratulations it feels like playing
like doki doki
literally so this is the new gameplay
mode push
and um
there's a big robot
i mean there's a lot of big robots there
it is that one there and you basically
have to stick close to it and when you
do
oh lord it moves forward and pushes that
platform
or that barrier forward
and then that is how you measure
who is winning
power me up please
oh it's also worth mentioning too for
people who did sign up for the beta i
think it's happening in waves yes this
is like everyone all at once right at
the beginning it's this is the first set
of people and there's gonna be more
people throughout the day and throughout
the next coming days i guess
so you still have a chance yeah you've
got chances
come on shoot me
i'm here
apparently we're we're streaming at 480p
somehow are we
yeah i guess so
uh
surely it wasn't intentional no it's a
thing that everyone likes to look at the
transporter and look at it
well
yeah i usually stream at 1080 so i don't
know what what is going on today
there's been a road setting or something
yeah
i don't know what the deal is
this is a payload race kinda yeah
like now that we're not on the point
they're gonna push it back a bit you can
see in the top the progress left side
being asked us how far we've pushed it
right side being them
why is this streaming at
so low that's annoyed me now
i assure you the game uh does go higher
oh my god it's young andy cortez kind of
funny's very own andy cortez has
appeared
in our
that's amazing
that's a what a delightful moment that
was
oh she's back
all right
yeah critics there's going to be more
invites going out as as the beta goes on
you'll get an email that tells you
you've been accepted and
you'll be able to jump in
oh i'm almost done with my download
which means i can own this job
it's gonna be so mad then if it works
for you and you just jump right in
immediately
so everything's fine no waiting at the
screen no queue times just
getting it and going
oh lord no get me out of here
oh god i've been hacked
oh god they're behind us
oh yeah you can also get codes through
your drops yeah twitch trunks
so that's another way of getting oh god
please
oh yeah the ping system i forgot about
that
good way to let people talk or talk to
people
i forgot about that i'll do some pings
now
not randomly i'll do in-game
everyone just looking at apex legends
andy cortez snow bike mike they're all
here the whole gang is here blessings
her wow
you'd love to see it
oh my god
that was a ping
i just don't know
okay
that erisa move is
wild
yeah
yeah it seems pretty pretty nuts
yeah
i wonder if i should restart the stream
and in higher quality
someone asked john luke if that's
something we could do
[Music]
let's go in the robot
he runs back to the point a little
quicker
which is good
keep on moving buddy
let's go
oh no
nice
oh my brother is playing everyone's at
it the gang is back
everyone's back everyone is here all
over again
they love to see it
okay
it's kind of neck and neck here
where he should go
oh god
i wonder if
yeah so zarya's abilities are a little
bit different now you can see that she's
basically got two barriers that she can
use any way she pleases i can either
barrier two separate two people that
aren't myself or i can split it between
myself and them
um which is a cool new strategic
consideration for the character
um
she doesn't feel great like she doesn't
feel like she's more
viable to me
she still kind of gets
bullied a lot
i would love i would what i want most
for her is like an escape tactic that
everyone seems to have
to a degree or not
like the way to disengage
from the game
from a skirmish
[Music]
yeah we're
we can we can probably change the the
resolution between games it's probably
the best bet
you're feeling it
on on my stream i don't think so yeah
i mean like
oh yeah yeah yeah if we have to restart
the stream yeah
yeah just as a
thing that
john luke says he's down for okay
also i'm gonna jump into the game now
because it's it's here it's arrived it's
alive
uh let me check what the
um i'm so sorry jordan i mean
i feel like i should just give up and
just come back to this like in an hour
you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna
leave this game all right folks in the
stream what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
end the stream briefly
i'm going to change to 1080p hopefully
or at least higher than whatever it is
um and then
are you in ben
uh i am in
okay let me add you to the group
uh how do i add you to the group
social
boom
oh no it says unable and invited by
there we go i invited you did you get it
i'm looking around
i don't see anything yet
can you join on me
uh that is the next thing i was going
for and it i have an invite to group
option but not anything to join
it says player not found oh no
i've been deleted you've been removed
you've been removed are we oh can you
check if streams back up now
um refreshing
and
says offline still
really
yeah at least on twitch
okay
i think you're live on youtube okay
let me check
twitch
got a cool
350ish people on youtube
uh
let's see
okay
uh ben can you try restarting
your overwatch client
and
do
okay
uh
while we're waiting we can try taking a
look at some of the heroes
i don't know who's who's really changed
everyone looks kind of
the same
nice
um
i'm just doing fist
i can't believe doomfist is a tank now
he's a tank thanks very much
um
jordan can you check if we're live on
twitch and if not help jl and twitch
these are obviously my skins here's
let's go to the new character where
i
is
she
see it on twitch there she is
uh
you are not live on twitch
i don't i don't know what's going on
then
i'll let him let him know though
okay let me try adding you
to the group and we'll play
is this player not found again
you don't exist
it's a beta hey
i got the thing
i could just queue up at the same time
as you will do like a countdown
if you do it enough times and you're on
the same server
all right
wow i don't know why it's doing that
i try to invite you and see what happens
yeah go for it
yeah that worked
perfect
sweet
uh all right cool just do it on ranked
yeah yeah yeah
uh i'm just gonna i'm gonna hit it up
i'm gonna go right for it
do it
ready
sick it's this is way smoother than i
thought it would be
for now
for now
you've just jinxed it yeah you jinxed it
oh
i've got heels again
you know what
they put me right in the spot to try out
my my dude i've got to do it
who's your dude ben oh it's reinhardt
he's a good boy i'm a boy
yeah yeah
i don't understand why we're not live on
twitch
i i did give
jean-luc a heads up about it
very strange
okay we got we got cool buttons
uh my razor keyboard of course is uh
overwatch colors now
nice
okay
remember ben you are one and only tank
it's me
i'm i'm doing it
and she hear that
yeah he hit his head yeah
oh my head
back up jordan can you check on youtube
if we're able to switch if you're able
to switch to higher quality now
uh
i'm capped at 480p what is going on i
don't understand
it's the beta
no but it should be my streaming
yeah my stream setup is causing that but
it's at
six thousand
see if jean-luc has any answers
let me just refresh oh this is bad oh no
oh no
oh no they're coming for me
they on my ass save me
junkrat please
yeah get him get him get him get him
oh i just jumped off the map with him
let's see if i can make a recovery no no
recovery
i followed him to death
make sure we get more of us so far
there we go
this uh a shield don't last as long no
blizzard really looked at overwatch and
was like look time to kill is too long
yeah lower that stuff
a lot of people do not have patience
anymore
[Laughter]
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god
dangerous
yes
okay so we got the point that's good
oh god
oh god
damn
i think what might have happened is the
restream broke
oh when i stopped because i don't know
how they do it but um so i think that's
a jean-luc thing
i cannot explain the quality though
there is a charge beats my charge
my charge is here for longer
oh so close
i came so close to raising you
let's move
yeah for people asking why it's in 404
aep i wish i could tell you
all my settings say 1080p
but you know
i'm getting none of it
it's frustrating
a lot of people are like looks like
overwatch one and it seems like it plays
like overwatch one kind of forgetting
that overwatch one is a really good game
yeah i mean of course it's gonna look
and play like overwatch one that's kind
of
the multiplayer is the sequel to
overwatch one
it would make no sense if they were like
well this is a great game that everyone
loves let's change it completely
i have no idea if it supports ultra wide
but i'm sure i'm surely blue
overwatch of course it supports
ultrawide it's got reinhardt in it
there you go he's ultra red
look at him
hey
it's jim raynor
that's the guy that's a guy
what are you doing here jim
object
showing up
that's a cop out but okay it's not a cop
out it's just the truth
can you believe that they made uh all
the call of duty games multiplayer so
similar wild
it's true it's so can't believe they
didn't weird i can't believe they didn't
change call of duty to a racing game
after the first one
i've always said call of duty should
have been racing to be fair the quality
games do mix it up quite a bit
but not in a crazy music
so basically people just wanted the
for blizzard to just take the uh respawn
approach it's like no we
like no titanfall 3 make apex legends
yeah
completely different game different game
what is the ping button by the way
middle click
gotcha for me i believe
why not just keep updating the first
game then
i don't know
it's a good question i mean they are
updating the first game i believe it's
they're trying to keep it parity between
it right
yeah so i
feel like that made way more sense when
they announced that like what was it
like four years ago yeah these days just
like not as much the two part of it is
all the single player stuff and the rpg
stuff that they added to that
um
this is gonna feel very familiar because
they need the multiplayer to play a
similar way
because
that's their multiplayer experience
like i said it mixes this up more than
this i don't think cod mixes it up yeah
no it's quick
i mean it does have
yeah true yeah that's true should we add
godzilla add godzilla to overwatch oh my
god please
they seem insistent on never giving us
any godzilla games anymore so like yeah
we're putting them in everything
shot of face wants to know does it at
least feel different even if it looks
the same
no it doesn't feel different again
feeling different is not what they're
going for with this why would you wonder
look tam it was a perfect 10 out of 10
game and we were like this is what i'm
saying like i can understand the impulse
for everyone to be like oh it needs to
look feel and play different but that is
that is almost ridiculous to think about
some changes
holy cow
like the thing that you want if you want
it to look feel and play different is a
different game
like play that you need to find another
game that is not called overwatch
cosmetics may i suggest valorent or like
i don't know load up team fortress
orisa's mean
she is she's rough
like real mean
yeah a lot of the stuff that will earn
the two sequel part of it is not in this
beta because this is a beta of
multiplayer they don't need to test the
the single player portion of it right
now
um so that's the stuff that what's this
while you wait over here
oh um so the stuff that is going to earn
that to monika
either fairly or unfairly
properly or not will be the single
player stuff or the
not the single player stuff the pve
stuff
i'm going to do some real bad shots with
uh honor
so i do feel like the whole overwatch
two thing though would have made a lot
more sense if it had just been a clean
break away from the original game
because like you there is i think some
logic to be like well eventually some
games just like you need to
move away just to
update the game because it's like oh the
original
files for this game just can't really be
expanded on anymore so people are asking
why not update the original the original
is being updated there is they they said
they're going to try and keep parity
with this game with this game and create
like a cross-platform thing where if you
can play if you have overwatch one you
can carry on playing multiplayer
um the stuff that they're doing
according to blizzard the stuff they're
doing for pve means that they need to
create a new kind of like client because
the original one can't hold on to is not
um going to work for that
well i just want to stay back in the
back and curl golems pearling in there
there's a genji behind us
my my shots were on there's something
about anna that um i really want to like
her
but there's something about the feedback
and this is not specifically overwatch
too it's overwatch one as well where i
feel like i never hit a shot ever
maybe it's because i'm actually not
hitting but like
i feel like it needs a enemy
they do have a long range support
character though so it's really cool
yeah i've wanted them to add a character
like ana to apex legends for a while now
where'd he go where'd he go
he's up on the wall now
okay we got we got a disengage from this
genji man
yeah
he's getting exactly what he wants i
don't want to give it to him
playing lost like a damn fiddle
just want to hang out with my robot pal
robot friend
yeah push that thing
he's very vocal
it's true he likes to let you know
oh lord
is basically just the the vanquish
character right is that what the
vanquish he went for vanquish
of all the characters that can slide and
shoot in the modern day you went for
vanquish
what's the one that sticks out in my
mind
that's fine
he invented the slide
you are correct oh no i just tried to
put the robot sleep
that doesn't work
it still feels good though as a game
i think they're one of the things that
people quickly forget because it's taken
for granted is how diverse the gameplay
models are in this game
like the tricky thing is
um for a lot of other games or for
overwatch is a lot of other games they
have the same basic gameplay models
right like in a call of duty the only
real the mechanics are shared they're
uniform if you're playing one of the you
know modern ones you've got maybe
parkour or whatever
and um otherwise the differences are
come through
uh
your loadouts like how a gun feels or
like how a grenade operates or what
perks you have that kind of stuff
whereas overwatch is the strength of it
back then and the strength of it is
still oh when i do that is like every
character is plucked from a different
game and feels different
um and that still is kind of the magic
of it right now it's less than somewhat
because we're used to it but it's still
something that i really really
appreciate playing now like social feels
like a really interesting mix of a
classic quake style character with her
railgun um but then also you know she's
got the mobility of a
modern you know battle royale character
um
with the slides and that kind of
business
which i think is cool
oh falls
that also makes the criticism of why
does it look and feel the same or why
does it look the same
like not as
valid because
the same is a bunch of different super
diverse
characters with a number of different
gameplay mechanics that all interlock
and engage with each other in
weird and wacky ways
i actually really like gundam evolution
i'm not even gonna lie
yeah
i didn't decidedly get a chance to play
it
but it seems cool
yeah i love me some condoms it's ticking
oh god the like the gameplay of this
that you know works really well and just
lets you do it with gundams
which i'm never gonna say no to because
i love me the giant robot
it is goo it's me
i'm i'm over here trying to work off my
overwatch rust
anna okay i just need to land
my goal is to land some more sleep dots
which i'm terrible at apparently
uh brighter work for me
it's not going very well admittedly
at your service
who's coming someone's someone's here
oh no i screwed that up
it's all right tam we forgive you
i just like i think i just tried to
sleep dart a lamppost
hey
robot no
i screwed that up
genji excuse me
genji man
oh man
uh they're like jumping off the walls
and stuff and just put themselves in
between whoever is charging at
i love it when that happened survived
yes
i didn't get him
oh who's behind oh
cassidy
oh yeah hey
it's that's a victory
oh my cat mug i forgot hey
jordan have you made any progress
oh to be completely honest i stopped
checking
i just started reading chat instead i'm
like this will get more productive you
can monitor chat for us and let us know
how we're doing
okay
let's see who we get next
time to heal again
did i get healed again come on
i want to shoot stuff
they're like man this damn guy is just
so good at supporting i'm not no one
wants to play support so
[Laughter]
can i get a better mirror oh man
i got default moira
skin
hey look we've got someone called
radicus
on our team
rad radicus
the uh forgotten son of radigan and
america
ben you left
ben's gone awol
ben's gone
oh no what's happened to ben
ben's internet has given out
it seems like
it's all falling apart
yeah
how did you get back here
oh no
behind
oh is that
i cannot tell you how annoying i find
doomfists
to play as or to go up against to go up
against they just do the same thing over
and over again uppercut
and then out of the way that's kind of
like that's his yeah that's his like
loop but it's like so annoying because
i'm like okay let's fight and then
they're gone and you're like all right
coward
cowardly behavior stand your ground
you've got a big punching fist fight me
no
this ends now
oh my god
oh i see what i'm talking about
it is the way
joseph in the chat says bro playing
tracer and whining about doomfist joe of
course is a fake gamer because i'm
playing as moira
so if you're gonna try and be lame in
the chat at least be accurate
loser
come here
uh zero ass oh wait no
was that zero no that was canadian bacon
so the character's just not getting any
overwatch to default so are some
characters just not getting a new
overwatch to default skin i think all
the
yeah i think they're mostly oh yeah
yeah
i can't think of
maybe bastion
no i think he's been updated
enhancing your vitals
how did he get away
where'd he go
i hate to see it
bothersome
oh
oh here we go
what where i didn't see the oh my god
this is a little uh
indicator that shows where his meteor
striking
evolution is painful it'll be nice if i
wasn't playing hilo all the time
just try any other raw
i'm not particularly good at heels
i'm always just getting myself into
danger
which is not ideal for a healer
i don't know why i thought that you were
uh
good at deals
who works at gamespot that is like
plays healer really well uh
i think we can all i can do a decent
mercy but mercy's not really super fun
to play anymore
um
but yeah i think lucy did heals for a
while
but
i think she's a means diva now
oh no
no opposition is instrumental
oh we've got to impress now
i need help
[Laughter]
just come back from a
fight hello there
very obi-wan yeah i need healing
oh
oh he's back
what happened
it's real windy out here right now and
the wind knocked out your internet
connection how's that work it's it's
just tossing the wires uh it's just
flinging why is that
yeah
but uh back for the time being it seems
so that's good
this wasn't a long one oh my god i'm
getting clapped
time again to try again
maybe not maybe not
that's all connected that's all good
[Music]
if i can invite
you sounds good i'm uh should i help you
no it does not work
don't feel like making anything i'm
gonna order something
send it to you then
hey dude at least at least that works it
does work uh
for lunch i i have no idea
i'm uh
have someone have some overwatch eat
some overwatch oh there you go
continue somewhere i'll just
exist on games
i'm really curious what it is that's
keeping your game from like launching
properly
i don't know i should try it again now
that i've waited like a solid 20 minutes
any word on the next rollout i have no
idea when they're doing it
i just remember reading that i think
that's what's happening
back in the healer's seat again
it's true uh it is important to remember
that this is a beta uh
there's a lot that that needs to be
looked at adapted changed
uh
so that's that's how it's gonna go
oh no
oh
damn it that was you wasn't it ben
i was lining up the basketball shot
sometimes i just like just like to throw
my feet on the table my god
ah didn't even go up
this match is basically a whole wash at
this point yeah what's the point
let's take it back to the drawing board
i forgot what bunny was to shift and uh
lucio's abilities there i pressed
everything
it's like oh my god which one is it
yikes
well i got
wrecked there
oh my god there's so many of them
i'd toss me a pack
you happen again i press e to change
instead of shift oh this is bad
get
yeah drop in here you can see here
immediately like the 5v5 makes it
you just die way faster it feels more
death matchy
it does a little bit yeah
get out of there
who wants to go in the well
anyone
not me
i never want to go in
very wisely they're staying away from
the well
they know i know they're like not not
again it's happened so many times
oh up top
can i get behind him
what anyone
oh no
i screwed it up
again how people are kind of saying the
gameplay looks the same but like
there are so many things to change with
so many of these characters now yeah
uh
i'm finding a lot of it is getting used
to
just
finding out what new thing happened
where
like i got knocked up by something that
isn't something i'm used to what is this
yeah who did it come from
how can i avoid this in the future
i do not want this to happen ever again
i dislike it
not my favorite thing
i can't i shouldn't even bother trying
to put him in the will he'll come out
mccree's still trying to tell me the
time not mccree no he's different now
cassidy besties
need to get used to it still
don't do it oh someone already did it
okay so i stayed away from it this time
i was like
it doesn't even go up anymore this this
basketball is made of cement
hey we've got joey in the chat
the one and only oh
overwatch
go go fast everyone
okay
nope
sir
ma'am
man please
this is my favorite part
everyone's dead
looking back working back
you said that so sadly like someone
who's come back
from like a dangerous battle their dad
yeah everyone's gone
i'm the only survivor
oh geez oh geez louise
it's always erisa that that javelin toss
is sick
oh
it's pretty cool
[Music]
i don't know why i play lucio i'm really
bad at his movements
can we get on the point can we get on
the point
nope
we
oh
my jeez part
oh
oh my god
man
oh i'm not going to have that
i got honored i got honored
[Music]
score
one
two one
uh mega bird 700 in the chat says
actually do something besides answering
the question do something that compares
the two games so we can see why it's
actually different
uh no
it's a beta
i will not
don't tell me what to do
find some joy in your life
look at me i'm just i'm just surfing
they need to give
lucio the ability to slam dunk the ball
okay that's all i'm saying
before punisher is like hey question can
you play the early access version on
console no
yeah yeah they said they are going to
open it up to console soon
or in the future but no idea on what the
time frame is yet
all right i'm going to do that thing
where i hide in here
no and then get killed
it's taking some time to get used to the
new pace
yeah it feels way way quicker than i am
used to
i think i expect the fights to last way
longer than they actually do
but that's that 5v5
and also like the the considerable lack
of shields is very evident here
yeah like uh previously you guaranteed
shields everywhere in every game
but now it's just not possible
which means there's way more emphasis on
like skill
based play and also like good strategies
for flanking
which obviously we're not going to get
very
much of given our setup with randos
yeah and i think everyone's still trying
to figure out figure out what's
different yeah
little
much better
pizza
yeah she feels wildly overpowered like
from downtown that character is going to
get
some wild changes yeah
it's just a machine like literally and
literally and figuratively you can't do
anything to look i knew something was up
as as soon as they're charged beat
reinhardt so that can't happen
on come on come on come on
oh no
someone killed her as i was gonna boop
her off
it's live
okay
i'm gonna poke out from distance nope
that did not work i don't know which
side tank they're uh
hell over yeah our tank is a fight
so long suckers
they're they're living that new doomfist
tank life as best they can yeah
i probably got like maybe
four hours total in lucio in my life so
this is an interesting
oh my god they are just
hello
five man deep in there
oh i'm not winning this
i'm not getting away from it either
oh no
i can see that
this
got a firm grasp of what's going on
still
yeah
anna
get out of here
[Applause]
wow what was that
yeah that was weird that was so weird
that sounder was very strange
this is wild for me because i'm getting
all of your guys's commentary and then i
have to wait like
a few seconds to see what you're
reacting to
it's like a the zenyatta made like a
weird
sound as the old was coming out
so shawn is fun i would like to play her
at some point today please
be cool to get some some dps uh cues
maybe
but
it's how it goes i guess for the sake of
getting into games quick yeah
i'd say chris pereira told me is like oh
she's kind of like an apex legends
character i'm like say no more that's
all i need
uh a lot of people in chat are saying
it's very rude for you to only show
stuff from the previous game and nothing
from the new stuff
we don't control that okay it is
literally
oh my god
damn i would like you to talk to
blizzard and ask them hello mr blizzard
can you stop putting me on the maps that
are you point me on
oh hey healing again hey
i got
i might go roadhog
let's see what happens
oh we got some cool tank time
yeah i mean i if you want to immediately
see all of the changes that they've got
lined up so far read the patch notes
literally go to the website never read
the page
there's a lot of limiting factors in how
this stream is going we wish we could
just
like flip a switch and show you guys
yeah i wish i could go to just the all
the good all the new stuff but like i we
have zero control over what we're
playing
because that is how video games
work
wow
is the wii u of hero shooters
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
it's got layers to it
um
yeah i i think the only thing i could
really
talk to now at this point is just how
different the 5v5 feels yeah
it's quicker uh
it's it's more concise
i'm still making my mind up actually if
i'm i'm as into it as i thought i would
be originally but
yeah
it might just be the the adjustment
phase
it's also okay just to not be into
things then
that's true
but i would like maybe more than
four matches as
as healers only
to make my call on it nope you need your
full opinion oh right now
eva why
well what is roadhog's fire rating
that seems slower than usual yeah did
they nerf him slightly maybe
oh
yeah his fire rate seems weirdly slow i
don't know if i'm
what is happening with this
i just had a reaper try to jump me
coming out of the spawn and they just
stood still
i didn't
i didn't get it
come on lucio
i honestly don't know what they could be
i'm just trying to hang out and enjoy
this overwatch to update
try to tell you what you want to know
let's go let's go let's go this is all
good stuff tam this is all good stuff
it's not it's not working
ah you sneaky
ah
i biff that
do you know
i love the way you just tanked that diva
yeah it caught me kill though
you could have ran away and you're like
nah i'm just gonna heal
being lazy
oh no
he broke it
oh
i got one chevron that's fine
okay
oh jeez
wow how did he survive
oh balls
who is your go-to main cam zarya
there's a reaper on her as well now
we're in it we're doing it
oh my god what's going on fire right
oh
oh
oh
[Laughter]
okay
when i'm
[Music]
same
they really just yeah they just will not
let us play anyone but heels
like it's because everyone else is
probably queuing up to play the new dps
yeah
um which is very understandable
i wonder if you queued his dps and iq is
healing it would force us into uh
the game quicker
we could try that
yeah yeah let's do it
oh look at that cool me
uh yes
i
okay i'll go
damage
let's just both go damage let's see what
happens
i'm ready see that queue time fly yeah
fingers
crossed let's look at the heroes
the reason why they kept forcing me to
play healers like yo you're trash and
you need more practice
getting in here and do this
just a classic skin
sick
it's about to get real
is it now
here we go magneto
ah still cool look at that
there's my girl
they need to give them cooler outfits
going to give zarya about outfits that's
genji looking i got the green ranger
genji
one of the best looks yeah what a look
for him
illidan
carbon 5 is quite nice as well
wow i've not seen blue sheep before that
must be a new one
since i stopped playing wild
what other characters do we have
let's see what baptiste has got going
it's funky
baptist got them kingdom hearts feet
it's true he really does
yeah look at that
that's awesome
i like beardies
uh another minute before i i i'll switch
to healing
yeah
uh and you can stay dps so you could you
can at least
railgun some some people and slide
around
it's easier said than done
it's true
so once we get into the game we gotta
beat everyone else to it
oh
that's cool
thank you
i'm glad that all the skins that i've
already put too much money into getting
are still here
that's fair
mercy
dragoon there are randoms in the beta uh
and they're they're adding more in waves
as time goes on so if you're not in yet
there's still hope there's also twitch
drops and all that too
that's correct so
there's always a chance
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm yeah just do it
okay and we're gonna redo it
let's say all
this should this should hopefully work
better
okay
i'm i
i really do want to know more about the
the like the campaign solo yeah the
stuff outside of the the versus stuff
that's that's i think what's got me the
most intrigued
yeah for this game for sure
yeah i don't know when we'll get to see
that hopefully soon
yeah
that would be nice sure what's the they
get all this versus stuff settled and
kind of
out of the way they'll be able to focus
more on it we'll probably see more
browse bowling game oh here we go
well i need to get rid of
okay
where is my
there he is
ice fisherman
a little fish on the back that's
guys yapping mouth there it is
physics something that are great yeah it
does get all my
chomps when you move it
there we go that was that was much more
amazing that's more reasonable
all right let's try
or what can she do again
powerslide disrupter shot
so she needs to charge up her rail gun
by shooting her assault rifle and then
you got one shot basically
we're in this together
big jumps
big jumps foster's wrong
cheers
five
wow that pharaoh is
on point
oh she shot that at my foot that was
impressive
i don't know if i could no there's no
sadly there's no um
like scope on jean's ability
oh god sorry
oh my god
wow that far is back again she's in
behind the lines they
they really know what to do yeah they're
pushing pretty well here
butt pig
come on vivian one name
yeah
arisa is a menace i'm doing no damage to
her
i'm doing like zero damage to her
she's like recovering immediately
what yeah that is a
am i menace
god damn that pharaoh will not leave me
alone
that pharaoh's really good yeah she's on
my ass
she's like oh look who's playing with
the new character yeah i'm just gonna
make sure that i attack her non-stop
that slide though
yeah it's a good flight
oh
that's a lot of extra help oh wow that's
a lot of me being dead
i think the pharaohs killed you like
seven like four or five times by now
yeah
like it's it's much everyone's squishy
as well now because of the fewer um
shields and tanks so
survivability is not super high
there's the pharah
it's it's gotta be the
oh no it's not the old
no it's probably there
oh it's it
is yeah
i thought the other one was better but
that's just yeah that was
well this is like two individual kills
first as well
uh
impressions so far for for me at least
i've i haven't done much besides heal
and didn't play a tank once but
uh the switch the five
five five is is interesting
it it's making things go much quicker
but uh
i'm i'm kind of into it i i feel like i
need more time with it maybe playing
more roles yeah
that was the first dps match we played
oh i played anyway yeah
uh but i mean it's still the same kind
of good feeling like overwatch
oh gameplay just shoots a javelin now
that pins you to a wall also has a thing
where she could charge on you with a
spinning
spear in
a completely different hole
yeah uh and you just find little things
like that throughout the entire cast
that have been swapped and moved around
but i'm enjoying it
it's fun oh
yeah
um let's try sojourn again hopefully we
won't get
into a manchester with that pharah
that just
hates me what i'll try uh try doomfist
because he's a tank
a completely different role
uh
power slide disruptive shot
roll okay passive movement speed may
increase okay
that should be good
but
you asked to change
i learned too young that my body
couldn't always keep up with me
besides
it's hard to turn down rocket legs
it is hard to turn on rocket legs that's
that's the lore we're here for
i would i wouldn't turn down rocket legs
if someone offered me a
big save to just replace your legs out
right not if like you needed the
replacements you're just like oh yeah i
mean if they were like you'll get rid of
your normal legs and we're putting
rocket legs there i'd be like all right
as long as i can still walk and do all
my usual business that's fine
the added benefit of having rockets on
my legs why wouldn't i take that
because then you have to
do like maintenance on them that's then
it's like taking care of it i presume
they'll give me like rocket leg
mechanics as well
this is your rocket leg this is your
designated rocket leg mechanic
you have to pay your designated rocket
leg mechanic
it
god she put up quite a fight before you
actually right
so
doomfist may be a tank now but
still not very good with them as it
turns out the extra health definitely
helps
oh no it's aretha
they're back
for vengeance
i'm not very good at standing on the
point though so that's good
tracer
that actually worked
what did that miss
how's my f5 not working anymore
oh no oh
uh joey would like you to know tan to uh
charge up that rail shot i am
see i just did it
joey pay attention
oh no
what am i missing god that slide is
filthy
it goes for much longer than you expect
like you can use it to twist around
you can really like get around
i like that they're all
fighting completely away from where
they're supposed to be yeah i'm just
trying to keep them busy however
i don't get it i mean i guess it is a
beta and we're just trying to like see
how the characters work mostly but like
oh
i want to see 100 power from now on
let's go vivian
oh no if i don't back
oh no
are under the new maps even in the beta
yeah there's a couple yeah
okay i think the new york one is there
yeah
yeah we played them we played the newer
mode two yeah we had like one game on it
hitting the ground running
switching tracks
what
how she escaped that
oh god
thank you
i wasn't whining honor
come on she's so low
oh my god
oh god
switching tracks
come on wise
doomfist shotgun does a lot more damage
than it did before
or whatever is hand yeah a shotgun
to this
yeah that's good that's real good yeah
oh
oh yeah only one one new character so
far
they've uh they've shown off
oh there is a
i haven't got a good feel for how
how much damage you're required to give
out
just a little bit it seems like before
your railgun
is like powered up
don't seem like a lot
chat wants to know what keyboard you all
use
uh i use a mechanical keyboard
it's like a key crown or something like
that
mine's like an old razor
i don't even remember which one exactly
oh dang it you're such a gamer then
i am it's true i need to play lp's in my
rgb otherwise the games don't run right
get yourself together
i see that still is
my my keyboard is literally lit up
because of overwatch blue in a different
one
that was so close
i could really use a
a scope there
that
javelin
is so wild
it just locks you in place
oh my goodness
if they won't quit neither she can
really like push you out with the with
her spinning
javelin thing
ah
i think we need a little bear healing to
do a push
yeah that's not going to make it
you hate to see it almost
almost
true
close but no
cigar okay she looks so evil
i mean she is evil but
i do like the time of day the lighting
stuff difference in this map yeah it
looks more pronounced hair than anywhere
else at so far that i've seen
yeah i appreciate it to get that
it's a nice a nice little thing
well the games just keep rolling
um
let me try soldier i saw some people
saying they want to see some soldier
all right let me get a difference
yeah not alpine soldier let's do
grill master
every
i'm over here i'm
the greatest olympic sport
speed sweeping
how does someone get into curling what
do you have to do in life that you're
like i don't think you get into it you
just burn it in it like
either
you either curl or you do not
your birthright is curling
i mean i was a robot friend
wow where did she go
how's well
someone just just knocked out some glass
window
uh it was the most intense thing that i
didn't realize you could do
is he blocking
that was wild
if you want to know all the all the
differences you're probably better off
reading about him uh but the game it
feels different with the change to 5v5
yeah
and you've got a lot of character
changes
aris is not the same character at all
um
to to a a
maybe problematic extent yeah she seems
very
very powerful
um
she's gonna get nerfed i know it i can
feel it bones yeah
there's some some new maps
uh
this new mode we're playing right now
is on one of them he is blocking
wow i never knew he had like a block
move
yeah this is just the beta though like
there's it's all the single player stuff
that they're doing too and all that
that's that's not any part of this
so that doomfist was using his giant
fist to block bullets
yeah that's just
his new thing
just like a real tank
and then if he if he blocks enough it
powers up his punch
i don't know
if that is his new thing
oh the robot blocked my
my head
wow
i thought we were pals
robot is
betraying you
can't believe it
i'm still fighting
yeah it is set up where like all the
stuff that we're seeing
right now is is going to be in
everyone's game anyway right
like all this multiplayer stuff is
like you don't have to pay anything for
it it's just you just get the update
when the game comes out yes
so like this isn't 60
whoever's upset about that
this you've already you already own this
someone is
someone in the chat is this guy
streaming is a scam
what
no one forced me to be here
what am i trying to scam you out
man lucy really likes soldier more than
soldier
i mean
i don't know i just feel like the
movement that
surgeon has in her kit it is good but i
feel like her movement works way better
if you can really land those railgun
shots
because then you can like leap into the
air get behind and then like pick people
off i feel like she's she's going to be
like really well played in like
overwatch league
where they're like competent at doing
like weird trick shots in the same way
that they always like widow
yeah
yeah
just doing the blocking thing again
it's annoying how dare you try to take
your shots
how dare that tank
look at tank do what they're supposed to
do i can't believe this
i don't know where that is
yo if the tank wants to run away from me
as a healer that's fine i'll keep
chasing down
all right come on robot let's go behind
oh got me
i think i think the big differences all
of you guys are looking for
are are going to be in that
single-player stuff
uh
probably not in the in the multiplayer
where they're just doing a bunch of like
balance and additional stuff
is the pve single player i thought no
it's like i think it's co-op
campaign stuff is probably more accurate
yeah
i need to get behind them so i can do a
a little alt
a little
just a little bit
ah
is there any reworks to hanzo
yes i believe there is something with
his like arrow bouncing
oh his scout jordan can you check up on
the um hanzo changes
yeah
i think his like scatter shot might be
different
ah actually fell down
i got hacked damn
hate to see it
i like accidentally jumped down when i
didn't mean to ow my elbow
and the the game's still a far ways away
too who knows if we'll get more
characters or not
uh i mean it's not like you're you're
paying for the new characters either
let's go robot
that's my guy that's my robot guy
this changes must be so slight because
like no one is wrecking about it no
one's like broken it out i thought hanzo
yeah i thought hanzo had more
significant change but maybe i was wrong
okay let's push up a bit
yeah yeah
here they come
oh he stuck me
i forgot he could do that
it's the same exact place same one
shape
the soldier's model is big in first
person he's a chunky boy
he's wearing a lot of padding as well so
you're like
we'll probably get one more one more
yeah
the only thing i can find for hanzo is
that
the damage of his storm arrows has been
reduced from 70 to 65.
massive huge
eat that hanzo means
all right this while you wait button is
like weird
firstly it says will you wait
and then also
very often uh beta baby
yeah big big placeholder energy huge
come on give us another one
it'll it'll come around
let me get there
i don't think they change
um jordan do you have tourbillon changes
by chance
i don't think they change tall changes
thanks uh
you'd be a cool one to see them maybe
try to rework a bit
somehow
because like he's he's fun he's exciting
he's got some big changes that already
happened to him a while ago
yeah i'd be into it
i do miss that level 3 century
rest in peace level 3 century gone but
not forgotten ever
okay let's see what hero
shield from his old scone now it's just
a generic overheal oh no all right i'm
not seeing any changes for torb
um i had a headlight
there we go
a little armor things you could throw
down
god the mecca queen outfit for pharah is
amazing
it's true gundam lady
revolution i think that's basically
what's happening is it's just being put
into overwatch one
like everything's just going to be one
thing yes at the end of it
overwatch one will get all the
multiplayer stuff the campaign stuff is
all tied to overwatch too
because that's where
all the new content is
yeah is is it exists it's more that that
campaign stuff this
this is still kind of the same thing
let's go baby more heels oh no
oh hell yeah my sandwich was dropped off
i'll be right back
do it
i can try and play mccree or cassidy
but i think cassidy's got a magnetic
grenade now but i'm terrible as cassidy
throw a short range grenade
that homes in on nearby enemies and
deals additional damage if it sticks to
them okay so
the short-range grenade is the main
thing with cassidy
here we go the important questions hello
that helmet in the back from metal gear
what character is that again
colonel it's gray fox
there you go that ninja is gray fox
that's cyborg ninja that's impossible
grey fox was killed in zanzibar
anyway that's my mandatory talking about
not what we're streaming about but i'm
allowed
mandatory metal gear impression
and i didn't even use it i'm talking
about final fantasy 14 oh no i pressed
the wrong button
they took away his stun yes they took
away mccree's stone i tried to use the
magnetic grenade there and still instead
just rolled
i'm not a mccree or a casualty player so
forgive my
poor performance but let's see if we can
at least oh no
i tried
i'm going to say it again
this is a problem
right
oh the range on that grenade is not very
far at all you basically are
underhanding it
god
i do get a chance to try
uh doomfist a bit as a tank and i i
actually kind of like his change more
like he feels better as a tank to me
if if that's any sort of impression
you're interested in
but uh he uh
he's got some cool blocks and
uh i like how it kind of weaves into
a bit of his uh
his float
so jacob asks how does it feel i think
we've mentioned it a bunch of times but
the main main difference here so far
just to reiterate is the 5v5 instead of
6v6
and that it does have a big knock-on
effect in the way it feels the game
feels a lot quicker now
it feels more like a death match in
moments
um
the skirmishes don't feel as drawn out
as you're seeing here
because there's less shields on in play
and if you've got a rind pretty much i
can't think of anyone else that has got
like a
a shield
um
that can get in the way ryan seems to be
that orisa doesn't have a shield anymore
winston's still got the winston
yeah
um but yeah it feels much quicker
and like everyone feels slightly
squishier
oh this is not going well
you did say you were not a cassidy
it's true
no
but yeah it feels it feels much much the
pace is much much quicker
which is which takes some getting used
to because you
you kind of have to um
you have to make your strategic
decisions much quicker
and your communication has to be better
i mean you've got the uh
paying system here
well i think the pink system is more
useful for when non-verbal communication
when you're like not playing with other
people
generally for me i found that like
if we were playing with a full stack it
would just be quicker to tell people
stuff instead of pinging them
but if you're playing with randalls it's
probably quite useful
god
you know what i'm going to take this
this is good
this is good
i'm going to get on that objective
they're probably going to come around
the back
yep they are coming from around the back
there's a sombarino there
another quick look up front see what's
going down
honestly we have no idea why the stream
is at 480p yeah we don't understand the
settings are correct
i made sure to check i don't know what's
going on why why it's like that
there's a uh somber on the point yeah
oh my god i'm getting flat
goodness
my goodness
can i throw my
just a minute
no i can't
interesting
oh
oh
almost going
almost got him
not jumping so you guys show up
changed
wow she's very very accusatory
oh who was that
come back coward
oh my god
they still haven't seen my ace
um
oh suck
i was hoping to be there
there it is
i think we're gonna have to call it
there
that's a solid four and a half
yeah
there we go look at this
some
symmetra's still out here being a menace
to everyone
i hate to see it
that beam is ridiculous
anyways uh thank you everyone for
watching uh there's various ways for you
to get into the overwatch beta yourself
is quickest way is probably to just go
to the website and sign up oh no cancel
um
to to go and sign up on the site and
they're doing um rolling
um uh
entry so even if you don't get uh
a an invite right now you might get one
in a few days or even a few hours who
knows
but yeah otherwise yeah if you go to the
blizzard
faq
page about the overwatch beta there's a
list of um
a bunch of uh
streamers that are doing drops for four
codes as well so you can check it out
there if you want if you want to try and
get access that way
but otherwise i think the sign up is
probably the best way to do it
uh thank you for watching we'll see you
for the next stream which who knows when
that is
keep an eye on gamespot.com and we will
be sure
to make you aware peace everyone bye